all right let's jump into this first
story we have this tweet from Miranda
Devine she says in 2018 Hunter Biden
claimed he owned the house where Joe
Biden kept classified documents
alongside his Corvette in the garage
take a look at this on this silly little
document you can see oh I can't even
scroll down I got to do it this way here
we go you scroll down and you can see
right here monthly rent 49 910.
he lived there move-in date March 20th
20s I'm sorry March 2017 to February
2018. so 11 months he's paying his dad
50 Grand and you can see current address
is the Wilmington address
what's uh what's Hunter doing spending
10 times the high end for rent to live
in this house I mean look you want to
talk about the documents that should not
have been in those properties you want
to talk about who else had access to
those documents at his pen his UPenn uh
office as well as his house and it all
sounds very dirty and then from that we
are now kind of discovering that uh
Hunter button I I think this is this is
this is evidence of funneling money
money surreptitiously to his dad now I
want to say proof but I it is possible
he fabricated that number and he's
trying to make it seem like he spends a
lot of money I don't know why you would
do that so I think this is very very
strong evidence that that's what he was
doing he was funneling money to his dad
well it is a lot of money and it doesn't
really make sense in that particular
neighborhood but hunter Biden is a big
spender he spends tens of thousands of
dollars on sex workers and on a lot of
drugs there's also a a text message that
the New York Post is reporting on
specifically detailing how Hunter Biden
allegedly was covering a lot of his
family expenses and giving as much as 50
percent of his earnings to his father
this is according to some of the text
messages through the laptop that were
leaked one specific text message reads
quote I hope you all can do what I did
and pay for everything for this entire
family for 30 years Hunter raged to his
daughter Naomi in January 2019. it's
really hard but don't worry unlike Pop I
won't make you give me half your salary
that's Hunter Biden texting his daughter
that's that's pretty telling there yeah
you say yeah what we see here is
evidence of washing money like you said
I'm not going to say proof but this
looks like they're doing the laundry and
I think this is real there's two things
Mega came in the house you just had Matt
Gates on Friday Mega's really they're
going to do the church like commission
and that's going to put pressure on
Biden that's why we're starting to see
some of these things come out in my
opinion and they have to look impartial
so now they can say we're going after
Trump and Biden and then on top of that
I don't think Democrats want Biden in
2024 are you serious yeah so it solves
two problems for them I think and Joe
Scarborough is on TV along with Mika
going after Biden because he's handled
this sloppily they had the message like
we don't think there's any more
documents out there than how many did we
see three or four now yeah the number
one thing with crisis management is you
nip it in the butt you say here's
everything and then you don't have to
talk about it anymore so something's
something's wrong I think he's in danger
you brought up a very good point because
you know the corporate media usually
regurgitates any slop he throws on the
floor and they and they love it they
suck it right up they spit it right at
you looking at you smiling as they
they're propaganda and their bull crap
they got him elected if it wasn't for
the corporate media the The Joe Biden
hiding in his basement would not be
president of the United States right now
also social media also the intelligence
agencies also a lot of black money but
that's separate topic here so I do think
there's something behind the scenes
happening right now it could be him
saying hey I'm going to be running in
2024. I'm I wanted to be the next
president of the United States and some
powerful people saying no you're not
you're going to play ball and you're
going to give this to bootage or Kamala
or Oprah or Michelle whoever it may be
but but I think there's a larger power
Striker and and it might not even be
around the election it could be
something related to the collapse of the
economy the globalists or
internationalists the the shadowy elites
could be like we're going to crash this
economy under your watch he's like nope
don't do it who knows what's going on
here but this smells a foot here because
this doesn't really add up to what
usually happens in Washington DC I think
it's weird because Joe Biden
is the establishment they don't need to
to do this to get rid of him
they he they could just be like all
right hey buddy we're not going to have
you running 2024 I'll go okay unless
they want to get rid of them early then
they're like okay here's how we're gonna
get you out early we're going to find
documents you're going to apologize it's
gonna be no big deal and then you're
going to resign maybe what if Jill
doesn't like kamla that's allegedly out
there in the wind and if he steps down
it would have to be Kamala at least at
first do you think it's possible that
they that I don't think they tell them
directly these are all signs that Joe
your time's up I don't think there's any
secret meeting where they come in and
say Joe don't run but do what do you
what if kamla is next in line and
they're like we don't want comb we want
Buddha judge or Hakeem Jeffries or who
else McCarthy
because yeah if if Joe and Kamal are out
the next in line for the presidency is a
speaker well I mean 20 24 20 24 yeah
yeah I don't know I mean I don't think
they need to do this to stop Joe from
running in 2024. they just need to not
give him the IV drugs they've been
giving them you know yeah just let him
fall asleep yeah man don't run him well
there's only so many replicas of him
that they have okay so they might be
running out and they're and they're
they're getting worse they're like
degrading in quality Joe Biden number
five is not doing too well okay sorry
Ian you had a chance at 50 000 a month
in rent is complete it's it's not normal
that that can't not I don't know if I
could say that can't be real is it
possible that a apartment buildings yeah
it doesn't seem real
tons of people have gone through the the
rentals in the area and the highest is
six thousand money average is like three
the IRS would in any other circumstance
would look at this and be like oh yeah
it's illegal yeah I would think so
that's also illegal what so if like Ian
let's say I want to give you a million
dollars you've got to pay a gift tax on
this there's a bunch of things you can
do but there's like 15 000 is the yearly
tax limit if I pay you a million dollars
you got to pay income tax on it and so
you get you get people who are like how
can I get the money to someone in a way
in a certain way right okay how about I
buy a painting for a million dollars
sit on it for a little while
then claim it's only worth a Dollar sell
it to you for a dollar you can then say
Oh it appreciated to a million dollars
and now you have a million dollar asset
you just have to pay taxes on it I think
what this is evidence uh so so anyway my
point with that is
the IRS tracks for these things because
you can't just give the money to someone
now rental income is still going to have
a it's going to be taxed so when I think
this is evidence of is not necessarily
that Hunter is trying to secretly give
money
you know as like as a gift I think what
he's trying to do is clean the money the
money's dirty so he's giving his dad 50
Grand a month in rent so that Joe can
claim on his taxes rental income and
then pay the taxes on it and now it's
clear yeah at its face that's what it
looks like if Hunter's taking money dark
money now isn't this very blatant I mean
this is out in the open
so why why would he think he wouldn't
get caught here because
he already got away with so many things
uh today he's also in court uh demanding
that his uh four-year-old daughter who
he had with a stripper not take his last
name so that's what he's up to today
that doesn't really say you know doesn't
really say the best things about him you
know these kinds of kind of actions
don't scream good father yes
they're trying to erase the Biden name
from is this a female as well a
four-year-old daughter he's claiming
that it's a curse
yeah
he's like she wouldn't live in normal
yeah he's trying to claim he's
protecting her from the abuse that she
might get for the Biden name which is he
must have been madly abused I mean if he
thinks that his kid's gonna be abused I
would have a feeling that maybe he was
he's playing games with it he just
doesn't want her to get the Biden name
so he's saying I'm trying to help you
don't take the name
but the name actually would help her the
hunter is going to blow the lid on this
stuff in like a decade in the next
decade he already did when Joe Biden
passes away the way Hunter is going to
be coming clean and all this crap now
did you see there's they are so
cold-hearted they hung up stockings for
Christmas and didn't include that
granddaughter
no they included the dog the cat
everybody now I think her name was Navy
I forgot her name her name that's cold
yeah is the word for is the word still
bastard if it's a girl that's a good I
don't think so I think it's just a boy
but let me double check a bastet yes and
then on top of that I forget which news
Outlet it was they wrote a headline
saying that Joe Biden has six grandkids
he really has seven so the media so
whatever Biden does in his personal life
that's his decision as bad as it looks
but why would the media not report
accurate numbers yeah and the statistics
with fatherless homes are absolutely
shocking when you really start to look
at what happens to a family when the
father is not there it is absolutely
horrendous it is absolutely horrible the
possibilities of arrest of jail of of
murder of assault of crime Skyrocket up
dramatically now when you have you know
a father who's in politics who's been in
politics for so long he in Washington DC
DC for so long being the career
politician that he is that usually means
he has to neglect being there at home or
if he was at home he was maybe trying to
get into some shower that some kids were
into but that's a separate story I don't
want to get into great detail here but
but I think it's fair to say that Joe
Biden hasn't been the best father as of
course Hunter Biden isn't really showing
the best kind of father figures uh he
isn't really the best role model here in
this particular example as far as I can
tell bastards can be women boys or girls
any child born out of wedlock uh also no
bastard also historically called
Horseman that's [ __ ] Sun the full word
[ __ ] sun and then cribble horse
I don't want that label that's a vicious
one or son they're like no bastard is
better okay so they they don't how about
snow you know that's that's still from
Game of Thrones yeah that that way it
sounds cool yeah yeah snow is cool yeah
what are the judges like you can't be a
bite which can be a snow you get a name
from somewhere
yeah What a Sad family man it's like
it's like a royal family kind of they
act kind of like that yeah with that
drama on money you know what I was
thinking earlier imagine alien came to
our planet and landed in America and
they said take me to your leader this is
what would they think
it'd go outside yeah they're just like
this isn't worth it like just gone
um there's a story that just came out
maybe that's why they're not visiting
yeah I mean I mean these are ants they
show up like it's us yeah
like who's calling the shots here this
guy no no no no no I don't know I think
if they did show up they would treat us
the way we treat like animals you know
we'd sit back and watch and then be and
you know it's like it's funny because
you ever watch Meerkat Manor no I
haven't seen it's like all the meerkats
they go to war with like the meerkats
have war and tribes and stuff and you
know they talk about the leader and they
give them silly names that's what the
aliens are probably doing they're like
the Biden family is ridiculed by many
well I don't know if the islands have
British accents or anything like that I
forgot who I was watching over the
weekend but it was a YouTube video that
made the argument that if we do get
visited by aliens that alien would be
artificial intelligence because if you
wanted to have that kind of long travel
if you wanted to of course send
something why not just send an AI robot
yeah so that's what I think that's what
Elon wants to do with the Tesla bot
everything Elon Musk does is to get to
Mars and I think he knows that it's very
difficult to get out of there with the
radiation all that yeah I agree with
that thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time